what's up guys and welcome to Howie's
hobbies the channel where we discussed
the latest tech news and augmented us
tech products today we are taking a look
at why you shouldn't wait for the next
generation of GPUs unless you are
willing to pay a hefty price for it
but before you begin that make sure to
subscribe to this channel if you haven't
already you updated with the latest tech
news related to gaming and pcs so what
happened and why is there more hype
about when these new GPUs are going to
come out well at GDC gamers Nexus was
able to get in contact with SK Hynix
who is the memory producer for Nvidia
graphics cards and they told gamer Nexus
that they're going to put begin
mass-production of GDD are six memories
in just three months so this summer GD r
6 is what we expected to be part of the
next series of gaming graphics cards
from Nvidia so this signals that the
next series from Nvidia is coming out
very soon unfortunately we didn't hear
anything from Nvidia about the next
series of graphics cards but this is a
very good hint that next series are
coming out just this summer so how is
the performance looking for these new
GPUs well unfortunately we don't have
any clues about how it isn't going to
perform because I mean even have any
clues about when I was recording to come
out but I think we can safely assume
that these new GPUs will match the
generational gap of last generation so
for example the last generation the 1060
was equal with the 980 and so
digitization I think we can assume or
safely predict that the 1160 will be
equal with the 1080 and last generation
2 980 in SLI were about or comparable
with the 1080 and so in some games the
1080 would do better and some games 980
would do better it really just depended
on how optimized the games were for SLI
so this generation I think to 1080 s and
s higher will be about equal with the
1180 so that's really good performance
you're basically getting 10 80 's and
sli as the 11 80 and plus there won't be
any optimization issues please it's just
a single graph this car
so as a result I think expect some good
things out of this new series of GPUs
and plus it's going to have the GDD r6
memory which is supposed to be twice as
good as gddr5 memory so this is great
and all but what exactly is this new
series supposed to come out well again
we don't have anything from Nvidia
themselves but considering the SK Hynix
is going to produce their GED r6 memory
in mass production starting in July I
think we can safely assume that the next
series of GPU from Nvidia are going to
come out near the end of this summer
this actually coincides with what Tom's
Hardware suggested just a few weeks ago
Tom's Hardware suggests that the next
series of gaming graphics cards were
going to be coming out at the end of
summer
and the last production was going to
begin in July Nvidia lexsha staggered
their releases so I would assume that
the 11 80 and 11 70s were probably going
to come out first in the end of summer
and then like other variants like the
1150 and 1164 the mid-level range will
come out end of this year finally other
select variants like the 1011 50 TI and
1180 TI will probably come out sometime
next year so that's the release schedule
that we can probably expect for these
new GPUs so everything about these new
series is sounding great they're gonna
come with great performance the newest
memory and they're coming up very soon
as well but the only problem is they're
probably going to be very expensive and
one month ago it was actually suggested
that the flagship of the next series
which would be the 1180 at least at the
beginning would cost $1500 and the
reason that they were saying this was
because that the 10 80s actually and
today TI's were so expensive like back
then to 1080 TAS were 1,200 $1,300 the
10 8 years are still priced pretty bad
but they are at least starting to go
down they were suggesting that the
flagship of the new series could not be
cheaper than the flagship of the old
series so it wouldn't make sense if the
11 a new is cheaper than 1080 TI but now
since that price it gotta start going
down I actually think that the uh let me
will be much cheaper than what they've
but why exactly do I think that the 1080
TS will accelerate their downfall in
price well if you guys didn't already
know it's here which is the most
prominent cryptocurrency that miners
with GPUs or mining is actually having a
really bad time last week a new ASIC
that was revealed which is specifically
designed to mine for aetherium and this
really affected the price of aetherium
aetherium dropped by $100 or 20% in just
a few days after the review and plus
this is just not a little dip this down
fast been occurring for a long time now
in the last three months
if 3m has almost dropped in value by
three times so if he wants to go idiom
was almost worth three times more as
what is right now not only is the price
going down but the difficulty - -
theorem is also going up and so that is
deterring more miners from coming into
the scene or - who are already on the
scene to sell their GPUs and this is
linked a lot of us GPUs on Amazon eBay
if you guys haven't already noticed yet
and if there's more supply then
obviously the price are going to go down
now - I recommend that you guys buy a
gpw for mining absolutely not but in the
grand scheme that should definitely lead
to a price drop in all G games so I
think that we can safely assume that's a
1080 TI or we sub thousand dollars by
the time that this new series comes out
hopefully it will even be in $800 or
even less hopefully the only thing I
should be keeping it up is the price of
RAM so if India does decide to priced
1180 more than 1080i then hopefully at
that time the 1080i should be more
reasonably priced so 1180 should not be
too overpriced but it's still going to
be expensive because of the better parts
that it uses and since it NVIDIA has no
competition first of all the 1180 is
going to implement GD d r 6 memory and
this is thought to be 20% more expensive
than what gddr5 memory was at launch it
does provide twice the performance so
that does make sense but it's still
going to be 20% more expensive and so
that's going to lead to a little bit
more price increase on top of that the
price of current generation GPUs will
unfortunately still be inflated due to
ramp prices and obviously got rent price
inflation it's also going to affect the
new series as well and if NVIDIA does
want to pricing more than current
generation that's also gonna realize a
price even more and also Nvidia really
has no competition there they have no
reason to price it cheaper they can
price it however they want and they'll
probably still make a lot of money
there's a lot of gamers who just care
about performance and a little bit more
money whatever really matter to them and
plus NBA's monopolizing and so even if
the gamers who are buying these cards
don't want to buy them lock them are
going to end up buying them because
that's the only option they have for
that type of performance the GTX 1080
came out at 599 dollars and honestly I
wouldn't find it surprising if Nvidia
launched this new series at six hundred
nine nine dollars or seven hundred nine
dollars or even more due to the GPU
inflation I just hope that's less than
eight hundred dollars but even more than
that is very reasonable and could be a
possibility people are still going to
end up buying a breeze with a much
superior performance and India is going
to have great sales and obviously people
who can't afford it are gonna get
screwed but but in the end in VF so
we're gonna be making more money than if
they were to price is cheaper and so
Nvidia will probably do that because
they want to make as much money as
possible especially with GP minors take
it out of the equation they're gonna
lose a lot of revenue so they will
probably try to make more money in the
gaming market and this can easily be
accomplished if they simply rise the
prices so that's the situation for
high-level cards so hopefully the
lower-level cards like the eleven sixty
alone fifty shouldn't be too much more
than what the ten series cards released
for so here's the gist of what happened
the next series of GPUs are going to
have some insane performance and are
probably coming out soon due to what we
heard from SK Hynix
however is also going to carry a huge
price tag due to having gdb r6 memory
and much superior performance and due to
the inflated price of GPUs right now on
top of that Nvidia has no competition
and they can get away with pricing their
GPUs higher than what they're actually
works so Nvidia is probably going to do
that and as a result the next series of
GPUs will probably be over priced when
they come out especially the higher
level cards like the 1170 and 1180
hopefully the lower level cards will be
less effective so as a result if you
guys aren't willing to spend that much
money on a GPU so there's really no
reason for you guys to get your hopes up
for this new GPU maybe a benefit you
because the current generation GPUs
might drop in price but the newest
generation of GPUs may not be in reach
for you guys so just keep that in mind
if when you guys are considering to wait
for the next-generation GPUs so the
takeaway from this is if you guys aren't
blame spend that much money then you
might as well get a GPU right now if you
think it's at a good price like for
example let's say a GTX 1080 goes under
SEP $500 or $400 which I probably don't
think is going to happen until the next
series comes out but anyways if you find
a good deal for any GPU and you don't
think your not before the next series
then you might as well go and pick that
up anyways what do you guys think about
this do you think anybody is going to be
nice or and more forgiving and priced
our GPUs like $600 for the 1080 like
last generation or do you think they're
gonna go up to 700 $800 because they can
make sure to post what you guys think in
the comments down below because I do
read all my comments and I'm curious as
to what you guys think so make sure to
post your thoughts also if you guys like
its video then make sure to drop a like
and subscribe if you would like to see
more videos just like this one but until
next time bye